This video was made possible by CuriosityStream.
When you sign up at CuriosityStream.com/Wendover,
you’ll also get access to Nebula—the streaming
site that Wendover is a part of.
Covid-19 is a devious disease.
It’s not deadly enough to kill a large proportion
of its hosts, so they go on to spread it to
an incredible number of individuals, meaning
its fairly low mortality rate has already
killed hundreds of thousands.
It disguises itself, presenting like a common
cold, yet can escalate to something far more
worrisome.
It also hides, with the possibility of being
spread by someone who does not exhibit any
symptoms whatsoever.
All together, this leads to one simple truth:
until there is an effective treatment, a vaccine,
or herd immunity, perhaps the most important
thing a healthcare system itself can do to
minimize the number of cases and deaths is
test.
Worldwide, diagnostic testing for Covid-19
has ramped up incredibly fast.
The first genetic sequence of the virus was
published on January 5th, and within days,
the first testing protocols were published
by researchers.
In the second half of January, the world was
testing hundreds of individuals per day.
By February, they were testing thousands per
day, then in March, hundreds of thousands,
and now, in July, 2020, millions of Coronavirus
tests are performed and processed each and
every day.
Believe it or not, though, this is not enough.
The process has been mired in issues and,
to get to the point where testing can actually
minimize the damage, rather than just quantify
it, we need to rethink the system itself.
The core of any Covid test is a laboratory
method known as a polymerase chain reaction.
This is a commonly-used procedure that copies
DNA or, through reverse transcription, RNA,
enough so that it can be studied.
The various steps in the process—denaturation,
annealing, and elongation—require various
specific temperatures, and so performing this
process requires a machine called a thermal
cycler.
These thermal cyclers can reach precise temperatures
incredibly quickly and accurately, but it
comes at a cost.
The cheapest thermal cyclers are priced in
the thousands of dollars, but the high-throughput
ones used to process COVID tests often cost
in the many tens of thousands of dollars.
Therefore, at this time, it is not practical
for every doctor’s office to have one, especially
as many less-automated variants require trained
technicians to operate.
There are some faster point-of-care tests
hitting the market, but they tend to be less
accurate, more expensive, and can process
fewer tests at a time.
Therefore, while samples can be collected
almost anywhere, processing them is a greater
challenge.
One of the largest testing providers in the
US is a company called Quest Diagnostics.
At the time of writing, they have processed
about 17% of all tests performed in the US,
and have the capacity for 130,000 each day.
They carry out this work in one of their twenty-eight
labs spread out across the United States.
Of course, it’s easy to see that there are
wide swaths of the country without a lab nearby,
so, to get samples from where they’re collected
to where they’re processed, they rely on
their own small logistics network.
This system involves plenty of ground transportation,
but also, in order to quickly transport samples
from far-away areas to the lab, they use airplanes.
Each night, after the day’s samples have
been collected around the country, Quest Diagnostic’s
fleet of airplanes get to sky starting at
around 7 pm.
These twenty or so aircraft are primarily
based in Reading, Pennsylvania and Lawrenceville,
Georgia.
As an example, on July 16th, 2020, one aircraft,
a Pilatus PC-12 registered as N338QD, took
off at 8:45 pm from Reading, Pennsylvania
and flew to Elmira, Syracuse, Rochester, Niagara
Falls, Allegheny County, Manassas, and Baltimore
where samples were trucked to the lab a few
miles from BWI airport.
The aircraft then returned to Reading, Pennsylvania
by 3:30 am.
On that night, the majority of their aircraft
focused their flights on the American south,
though.
This is a region without many Quest Diagnostics
labs and a surge of cases, at that time.
Another PC-12, for example, flew from Lawrenceville,
Georgia to Jacksonville, Gainesville, Tampa,
Orlando, Valdosta, Lawrenceville, Roanoke,
Manassas, and Greensboro, before returning
to Lawrenceville, all in one night.
Filling in the rest of the routes, you can
see just how much ground this small airline
covered in one night—stopping at a large
number of cities and towns, going to just
a few labs.
Now, in theory, a system like this, bringing
a whole countries worth of samples to a few
central sites, should provide economies and
efficiencies of scale, and, to an extent,
it does, however, other economic concepts
have simultaneously decreased its effectiveness.
To start with, there’s a heavy supply and
demand imbalance for crucial equipment.
To perform a test, about twenty different
consumable supplies are needed including nasal
swabs, transport tubes, reagents, and other
equipment.
Without any of these twenty items, a test
cannot be performed, so a bottleneck in any
one of those twenty supply chains stops testing.
In addition, economic forces are actually
decreasing overall efficiency.
Particularly in a country like the US, where
testing is overwhelmingly conducted by private
organizations rather than the government,
thousands of providers are each bidding against
each other for equipment.
In conventional economics, one typically wants
to avoid monopolies and oligopolies because
a few number of players have too much power.
This is why, in countries like the UK, for
example, where 75% of the grocery market is
cornered by four firms, products like milk
are sold for just about what it costs to produce—farmers
barely turn a profit.
That’s because, if a farmer can’t sell
their milk to Tesco, Sainsbury’s, Asda,
or Morrisons, they don’t really have another
option, so they’ll take any price they can
get and meanwhile, there are plenty of farmers,
so the grocery stores have plenty of options
if one says no to their low price.
Meanwhile, in the Covid test supply market,
the producers have thousands upon thousands
of potential customers, the testing providers,
so if one customer won’t accept a high price,
there are plenty of others and one that most
desperately needs the supplies inevitably
will.
If, for example, the federal government was
the only customer in the US, or just the largest
one by far, the supply producers would just
have to accept what the government paid because
there would be no alternatives.
Now, resources might not be allocated as efficiently
using a centrally-planned system, but it would
at least come at a lower cost.
In the real world, the larger providers like
LabCorp and Quest Diagnostics do have higher
buying power, processing more tests per day
than most countries, but they still have to
compete against the rest of the world in procuring
supplies, which increases cost.
In recent weeks, Quest Diagnostics, and other
major testing providers, have been able to
collect far more samples than they have been
able to process, and tests now take up to
two weeks, or sometimes more, to come back.
Tests that take so long to return are of little
use since many asymptomatic or mildly symptomatic
patients might not quarantine for that full
period while waiting for results.
Therefore, major focus has been placed on
how to increase the efficiency of testing.
For this, Quest Diagnostics received the first
emergency use authorization in the US from
the FDA to implement a technique known as,
“pooled testing.”
With this, up to four samples will be combined
and tested together.
If they generate a negative result, then all
four tests are considered negative.
If the group tests positive, then they are
separated and tested individually.
Now, if 100 people are tested traditionally,
100 tests will have to be processed.
But let’s say that 100 people are tested
using pooled testing.
In the US, on average, about 8% of tests currently
come back positive, so with 100 tests, grouped
into 25 pools of four, you would expect about
32% of those to come back positive.
For those positive pools, you’d then process
each test individually, so you will have processed
five times for four results.
For the 17 pools that came back negative,
you only processed once, meaning that altogether,
this pooled testing technique used 57 processing
slots to generate 100 results—effectively
almost doubling capacity.
This pooled testing technique, though, only
works if testing is widespread enough that
only a small portion of results come back
positive.
If an average of 20% of results came back
positive, as was the case in the US in early-April,
the efficiency would diminish quickly.
In that case, you’d expect to have to re-test
20 of the 25 pools meaning that, overall,
you’d use 105 processing slots to generate
100 results—more than if you just tested
them all individually.
Therefore, this technique does not work as
well for testing in hotspots, where positivity
rates are far higher.
Conversely, though, if positivity rates are
quite low, the efficiency of pooled testing
can increase as one could efficiently group
8 or 12 or 16 or more tests together.
Lower positivity rates can be achieved through
collecting more samples, so pooled sampling
can increase testing capacity, therefore increasing
its own efficiency.
But no matter how fast PCR testing itself
is, it is always a lagging indicator.
That is because it takes a number of days
for people to develop symptoms after exposure,
then more days for them to decide to get tested,
then more days for the test to come back.
That means that, realistically, it will take
weeks for significant upticks in transmission
to show in the data.
Therefore, some focus has been placed on developing
a more real-time indicator for COVID transmission.
The solution for that is sewage.
Sewage is naturally aggregated into a few
processing plants, so by testing it for the
presence of COVID’s genetic signature, one
can gain a more accurate picture of how a
whole area is doing, without the potential
sampling biases of clinical testing.
This technique can show if an area has coronavirus
transmission, but it can also give a big-picture
view of how much.
Not only that, but in research tests, sewage
testing indicates spikes about a week before
clinical testing, meaning it can help tell
governments if they should increase restrictions
before it’s potentially too late to make
an impact.
But let’s go back to the pooled testing.
Using sewage testing, you can know the relative
chance of a single person from a given area
of having Coronavirus, so imagine if you could
combine the sewage testing and clinical pooled
testing into one cohesive system.
This technique was proposed by a group of
researchers from Berkley.
If you know that, say, there was a 25% chance
of a test from Florida coming back positive,
you would know that it would be more efficient
to test that on its own, however, if you knew
that there was a 1% chance that a test from
North Dakota came back positive, you could
pool that test that with a large group of
other low-risk tests and save processing slots.
You could also, for example, know that a sample
from a healthcare or retail worker would have
a much higher chance of coming back positive
than a test of an businessperson working from
home.
The Berkley research proposes a system of
machine learning to scale pooled testing sizes
based on risk factors.
Low-risk samples would be grouped into large
pools, and high-risk samples would be grouped
into smaller pools or tested alone so that
pooled testing never leads to an efficiency
disadvantage, no longer the positivity rate.
The true genius of pooled testing is that
efficiency increases as test numbers increase,
so it only takes twice the resources to test
a population once daily as it does to test
once monthly.
Hypothetically, a pooled testing system designed
by machine learning could lower the cost of
a test to just $3 to $5, meaning the frequency
of testing could increase dramatically.
Now, we already know when the crunch time
will be for testing—Fall, 2020.
Sometime between October and December, each
year, there begins a massive increase in the
number of people catching the flu, which is
highly seasonal.
Covid-19’s symptoms closely mirror those
of the flu, therefore there will be a massive
increase in people exhibiting Covid symptoms.
Those people will want to get tested, to rule
out the possibility of Coronavirus, which
means demand will be higher than ever for
testing, even if real infection numbers are
lower.
All the supplies for testing produced now
are being used now, there is no stash being
built up, which means testing providers and
healthcare systems worldwide have a hefty
task at hand if there is to be any hope of
testing capacity matching demand in the coming
winter.
Like so many things going on right now, Covid
testing logistics and its issues are strongly
rooted in economic theory, and there’s plenty
more I could talk about, but this video was
getting a little too long to still appease
the YouTube algorithm, so I’ve posted an
extended cut of this video on Nebula including
discussion of exactly that.
Nebula is, of course, the streaming site that
myself and a bunch of other of the internet’s
top educational creators teamed up to create.
Instead of this ad right now, you could be
watching the extended cut of this video, or
any of our other videos early and ad-free,
or some of our special Nebula exclusive projects.
In fact, there’s a brand-new Nebula original
going out tomorrow from our other channel,
Half as Interesting, or you could watch Tom
Scott’s gameshow, Money, which I’m in.
We’re also super excited that Nebula is
teamed up with CuriosityStream, which is another
of the internet’s best streaming sites—home
to thousands of fantastic documentaries and
non-fiction shows, like their one on Gander
International Airport.
Specifically, on how it and the town reinvented
itself as it shifted from being one of the
most important airports in the world, to just
another small Canadian airfield.
Together, Nebula and CuriosityStream are offering
an amazing deal.
For a limited time, CuriosityStream and Nebula
are bundled together for less than $15 a year.
I’m confident in saying that that is the
best deal in streaming, and it’s available
only by going to CuriosityStream.com/Wendover.